він приїхав до мене Та й каже пане
Сандуляк Ви не хочете мені помогти
написати Ну звичайно я був не просто
хотів Я був дуже радий що до мене
звернувся сам левколок Яременко А я
запропонував назвати Акт проголошення
незалежності України і виступав проти
комуністичної партії
не буде України не буде Росії вони це
знають Вони це відчувають і вони роблять
все щоб їх щоб не було України ми
витримуємо
витримаємо правда Важко буде було але
витримаємо може після цього якраз
Україна почне свою нову історію
Сьогодні ми в гостях леонтія сандуляка
українського громадського політичного
діяча професора співавтора Акту
Проголошення Незалежності України
співзасновника Народного Руху України і
першого посла України в Румунію
івановичу цього року виповнюється 32
роки з дня проголошення незалежності
України ви один із співавторів разом з
Левком Лук'яненком Акту Проголошення
Незалежності України Давайте поговоримо
згадаємо про те що передувало цим подіям
є був
дипломатом СССР але в основному Я в
Києві сидів і працював і От коли
найкраще первин виникло я був якраз у
селі козиряних де народився і коли я
взнав мене перше що було 16 км Румунії і
це дійсно було б причина так думати піти
тому що потім
виявилося що я був в списках на розстріл
це десь біля сотні людей а потім
приїхали я зразу в Київ
у Києві там збиралася народна рада і всі
були дуже збуджені всі
решили проголосити незалежність України
Ну і народна рада на верху збиралася
ідуть туди Але коло п'яненко стоїть і
каже Та пішли там
каже Так хтось може мені поможе скласти
це документ зробити проголосити ну
получилося що всі спішили Кожен був
зайнятих він приїхав до мене Та й каже
пане Сандуляк Ви не хочете мені помогти
написати Ну звичайно я був не просто
хотів Я був дуже радий що до мене
звернувся сам левколок Яненко Ну ми сіли
де з ним пару годин і вирішили що
документ має бути дуже короткий
того що
234 комуністи у разі були вони
проголосують проти як ми складемо не так
Ну і те що Левко приніс з собою я
відредагував ну в якому плані там у
нього є вже не пам'ятаю як
називалося документом речення назву
документа закон універсал А ви
запропонували акт я запропонував назвати
Акт проголошення незалежності України
він аж аж рот відкрив
дійсно зразу зразу погодився А я кажу ах
це разом водія коротка Ну ми його склали
складали куди А склали так що ніхто
нічого не замінив замінив перше речення
добавив вірніше покійний по
ет
з Галичини
Павличко добавив перше речення там є він
бо він дуже хотів Що як так такий
важливий документ і без Павличко і потім
коли голосували всі усі проголосували
повністю за цей документ і в результаті
получається що є тільки два автори я і
Лук'яненко обліко Лук'яненко приніс з
собою з дому сіли зошит він ну все життя
людина
думала над цим в нього був вдома і часто
печатають у мене на жаль немає щоб
показати його і там в тому документі
викреслено дещо готов викреслили но це
що тут є 100 з документами Лук'яненко
пише виражаючи волю народу України до
життя в незалежній державі продовжуючи
тисячолітню традицію державотворення в
Україні в Україні виходячи з права нації
на самовизначення передбачено у статутом
ООН та іншим міжнародними правовими
документами та здійснюючи декларацію про
державний суверенітет України Верховна
Рада УРСР урочисто проголошує
незалежність України та створення
самостійної Української держави
республіки Україна ми потім забрали
слово Республіка Вони хотіли щоб
і депутати особливо Левко що в акті має
бути написано про тисячолітню
незалежність що Україна була завжди
незалежною державою розкажіть який опір
був
ніякого ну прочитали і проголосували всі
депутати підтримали значить акт був
складений Так що не було не було опору
навіть комуністи ніхто не виступав проти
чому підтримували акт і проголосували за
і комуністи теж їх питати чому Тому що
вони були за незалежну Україну вони
боялися і вони підтримали бо там
Гека ще пес закінчилося і вони боялися
що їх в тюрму посадять якщо не те так що
тут уже було запросто ніяких противників
Незалежності не було якби було написали
тисячолітню тоже би проголосували за
тисячолітню
до історії в нас дійсно тисячолітня
навіть більше тисячі літній історії
України
розкажіть про те як ви були депутатом
від в СРСР як взагалі так вийшло що ви
стали депутатом
і Як ви там себе поводили бо я читала що
ви були і проти Горбачова чисто
випадково
я
був професором зробив відкриття наукове
і
студенти зібралися в університеті
провести
вірніше утворити громадську організацію
Незалежності Коли почалися вибори
в Раду Верховну
СССР і студенти запропонували Моє
прізвище
я не пам'ятаю зараз Скільки ви десь
більше
80% за мене проголосували Хоч там було
12 чоловік да 12 чи 13
висунуто і списки для таємного
голосування внесли двох людей директора
аж заводу і мене
приблизно місяць
були вибори
агітація
я більше 30 зустрічей мав І деколи три
раз на день яку вегетацію проводили що
ви говорили в тому числі про незалежну
Україну але так
говорив про те що комуністичну партію
треба замінити що вона не може бути і
чому І все таке інше в основному проти
комуністичної партії
десь процентів більше 80%
пристаєвному голосуванні проголосувало
за мене і таким чином ви ставте покату
депутатом Я не був постійно а тільки
приїжджав на кожному
засіданні скрізь я виступав з критикою
це все Бо як тільки йде так і тут вони
не могли мені не дати слово і ні разу не
дали слова я сам до трибуни йшов а це
було дозволено бо так в Європі і я
завжди виступав у всіх Ну і таким чином
там є був але в основному я сидів в
Києві
у Києві я мавдора чи голос
я виступав
завжди в Києві виступав у Верховній Раді
маючи це право як збирав чого голосу от
У мене є Я не голосував за нього
Документ є
проти Горбачова я говорив що Та ми вас
знаємо як людину
політичну грамотно як то все але ви не
один державі
Якби було з кого вибирати тоді можна
використовувати
ще ваш обирати чи когось іншого Але ж ви
не хочете бо боїтеся що вас виберуть з
іншого якщо будете А розкажіть як
Горбачов питав у вас про Україну чи
скоро твоя Україна буде самостійною Я
йому сказав що буде то він мені ще тоді
спитав скоро тут ваша Україна буде
самостійною я йому відповів що буде
скоро але ви тоді не будете
Я коли би я став депутатом ті хто мене
обрали це Чернівці Чернівецькі і в
області Чернівецькій
це вони всі навіть
колгоспні газети всі районні газети усі
виступали проти мене і вимагали що треба
мене забрати з депутатів того що я
виступав проти комуністичної партії у
Верховній Раді Радянського Союзу була
опозиція 5 чоловік було в тому числі і я
входив
в
керівництво опозиції
Ну так
працювати приходилося багато
розкажіть про своє відкриття яке ви
зробили вона називається
еритроцити як Депос система транспорту
інсуліну і зараз як не дивно я
дивуюся щодо цих пір він енциклопедії
розумієте і інші вважають
кисень і вуликислий газ і все і вони
переносять всі
біологічно активні речовини але я
встановив це в основному для інсуліну
вистежувалися в Румунії стажувалися в
Канаді не стажування
надзвичайно в нас в університет має
зв'язок з каналом університетом між
нормальною я поїхав там там вже я
працював нормально звідти Я приїхав
політику А як так числа 04 місяці я з
українцями в тільки те я навіть на
північний полюс їхав на рибалку з ними
пройшло вони розказували мені я читати я
там вперше багато прочитав книжок вперше
в житті
перший Чорновола тоже прочитав і інші Ну
багато і вже є звідти приїхав з Канади
вже зовсім інший людиною
усі книжки які у нас були заборонені
в Канаді лише що мене вразило в Канаді
заходиш в бібліотеку не треба нічого
бере що хочеш але коли виходиш маєш
полишити книжку
і все я так
приїхав я з СССР і побачив
известия Комсомольську правду всі інші
газети які там спокійно будь ласка
читайте що про що ви говорили з ними
комунізм це все в основному обговорювали
вони показували фільм крутили там
показували їхні про голодомору Україні і
все це все це є вперше знав в Америку в
Канаді Я звідти вернувся вже
не радянською людиною
звідти я вернувся
українським націоналістам і тим ким
зараз є яким після того всього було з
Канади
до 4 місяці
вони мене перевихували розкажіть про
свою діяльність народному Русі я
очолював Народний рух
але ще є займався не тільки одним
професор Панчук помер минулого недавно
Він очолював фактично я як особа
політична
як відомо але фактично керував рухом
весь час Панчук
зробив Народний рух України Ну так
організація була
сильна велика зараз уже вона зійшла
як Всі
там були як я читала і були і якихось
комуністів до
націоналістів Але основне ядро це
націонал-демократи були Так це ви
правильно Народний Рух
вірніше входили всі
політичні сили більш в тому числі навіть
комуністи входили вони жили так між
собою спорили сперечалися і інші але
керівна ро все-таки було за демократами
в основному
професоресту дети
складали основу
Народного Руху
Ну а потім всі були там і робітники були
в народному Русі інші але Основну масу
складали значить студенти професори ідея
була проти комуністів про те що має бути
держава демократична виступали на зборах
усе як і в пресі всякі
проходили всякі
акції акції та Народний Рух проводив А
як ви сподобалося до Леоніда Кравчука я
ставлюся до нього позитивно
Кравчук зумів провести свою
проголосувати за розпад СССР фактично
це його величезна заслуга коротше
Він був дуже розумний вмів так і так
я критикував його і він
балотувався у Верховній Раді СССР я його
сюжеті
[оплески]
за це що зробили Що він не був він уже
коли
зробив мене послом
то він був дуже радий
що на кінець позбудеться
з Києва вони їхали перше делегація в
молдавську республіку ну вперше
їхали а я їхав з Чернівців вже
безробітної як депутат але не було
літака то години три ми сиділив цього
години три Я їм розказував про історію
Молдови Румунії
і потім
каже мені
секретар який їх
поїдьте з нами до нас секретарем Я кажу
що в якості когось я ніхто Ну він тут з
наверно долині домокаюся звернувся
розказав мене послали секретаря до них
це є поїхав в Молдову там ну просто його
потім мене відвезли в Чернівці потім
через якийсь час
отримую від Кравчука питання чи я
згодний поїхати в слово Румунію
першим ну
Я погодився Як вам там працювалося
дуже важко
вперше в житті я
погано і
сон поганий був і все До надзвичайно
важка робота була того що всі румуни
виступали проти України
А я в них посол запрошують
всіх дипломатів значить збори Ну і я
пішов зі мною поруч ще сидів По моєму з
Угорщини дипломат
Ну і це урочисті збори йдуть і всіх
виступають особливо з Молдови і
починають на Україну
критикувати до мене дивишся на мене як я
буду реагувати з
півночі Європи
посол дивиться на мене
ну я коли вони так я ще почали я встав
машину визвав і покинув збори
приїхав в мене дипломат був
він аж трясеться Та ви знаєте що ви
зробили це у вас виженеться це і кажу
знаю що я зробив якби я не зробив то я
би вигнав такого кажучи я кажу там де
ганьбили Україну я не захотів бути все і
показав це тим що покинув зал
Мабуть я далеко зайшов до румуни вже під
кінець
підпільно але почали
виступати проти мене
А в чому ви далеко зайшли
вкрийте сірогомського уряду ви там
хотіли ще щось домовитися про постачання
нафти було таке я ходив до кущі ми писав
Вірніше не писав ходив до нього
назустріч говорив він мене направив до
свого заступника його заступник
почав вивчити
нафти і ще в кінці кінців мені сказали
що ніколи не погодиться Кучма щоби бо
Вони мають з цього з нафти і не треба не
доб'ється тільки я так і не добився
нічого Що ви хотіли добитися щоб Румунія
продавала Україні нафту продавало
бо у них були залишки лишні А в нас не
було нафти а в Румунії можна було взяти
по ціни яка в Румунія може навіть
дешевше ніж в Європі ціна щоб не так
залежати від
російської от мені це не дозволили саме
України
Ну і Мабуть коли є багато чого робив що
не подобалося
це вони в кінці кінців вирішив забрати
мене
Чи є у вас відчуття що Росія хоче
повернути Радянський Союз є звичайно
Радянський Союз з Росії хочу повернути
бо росіяни може бути як держава без
України А для чого її треба повернутися
вперед Україну не буде України не буде
Росії вони це знають Вони це відчувають
і вони роблять все щоб є щоб не було
України
але їм це не вдасться не вдасться
але Вони думають що вдасться
отак
оце треба буде житися Коли розпадеться
Росія
з них не як держава
І що буде далі там буде багато держав
декілька але того Сполучені Штати
бояться цього щоб вони зникли як держава
і інші і ще політики в
світові це підтримуючи Росію саме тому
що бояться що вона розпадеться як
держава так Радянський Союз тоже
американці
підтримують в Верховній Раді приїжджали
захищати
Росію
А яким ви бачите майбутнє України
незалежно держава
в Європі одна із провідних
хоча це важко того що
українців від природи там де
два українці три Гетьмана
важко нам буде дуже важко буде
ми витримуємо
витримаємо правда Важко буде було але
витримає може після цього якраз Україна
почне свою нову історію
Дякую вам за розмову
прошу